bonjour donc bah bienvenue à la fabrique
c'est ici qu'on prépare le départ du
tour de france
transformation de véhicules légers ou
char fabriqué de a à z depuis deux ans
vincent et la vingtaine d'artisans de
cet atelier travail pour la caravane du
tour de france ce qu'il ya de magique
c'est que tous les ans c'est différent
enfin tous les ans en tout cas il ya des
choses différentes affaires il ya des
gros problèmes techniques on rencontre à
résoudre moi ça fait partie des choses
qui m'intéresse le plus ce que je
préfère c'est en dehors du fait que je
sais que c'est pouvoir dire à mon client
oui on peut faire n'importe quoi on peut
faire tout ce que vous voulez et quand
le client m'apporte un projet où je me
dis hou là comment je vais faire
en fait c'est ces projets là les plus
intéressants on récupère le décor on le
bricoles pour voir comment on passe la
capote
on conçoit toute la structure pour le
fixer sur le châssis 23 véhicules de 4
marques sont en train d'être créée
ils seront livrés 4 à 5 jours avant le
grand départ les chantiers pour la
caravane du tour c'est à peu près 20% du
chiffre d'affaires
le tour de france est un cas d'école
parce que on fabrique vraiment du hors
norme du sur mesure
et puis dans un cadre un peu festif
parce que le tour voilà ça a un côté
magique
les contraintes sont le cahier des
charges de l'organisateur du tour le
code de la route
et puis et puis les contraintes de la
marque bien entendu rendez vous le
samedi 1er juillet à düsseldorf pour le
départ du 100 4e tour de france plus de
10 millions de spectateurs devrait voir
passer les créations de la fabrique